did you have a pretty girl rep growing
up no I was a ugly duckling super skinny
like very
yeah list no no Talent no potential to
late growing up when kids make fun of
your name no they just make fun of how
white I was how white were they back
then I was pretty pale like I was almost
translucent so it's white kids making
fun of you on how white you are white
and white crying I always thought if you
were lighter then they would give you
props nice clean fantastic yeah talk up
to you white kids talking to each other
remarkable Ken Stellar dude excellent
work take us to the top CLE I knew you
were going to be the one but you still
can't play with us maybe nobody picked
me because they didn't know how to say
my
name clean or Colleen I would prefer
Colleen kin you like clean CLE come
yeah yeah that's pretty good